I spent years traveling the world but
I'd never been to Canada you know as a
professional surfer and someone who's
just generally passionate about the
outdoors
I'm really really excited to visit
Victoria and Vancouver Island as a whole
my favorite way to get to know a place
is embedding yourself with the locals
some am i doing dude they're always so
proud to show off where they live and
you also feel a lot more connected if
you go into an open mind what are your
favorite places to go sir brother you
know our beaches are about an hour away
Sean Barrow is gonna be sort of your
number one hit is there any motorcycle
shops or anything like that
check out wheelies there's a really
great sense of community at wheelies you
know it's really a special place for
bikers to hang out in talk shop
I had no idea vancouver island has so
much diversity the beauty of british
columbia's nature is absolutely
mind-blowing but within all the
stretches of seemingly untouched nature
there's all these little vibrant
communities and cities and just so many
things to do all from the surf shop and
ian took me to Sombra beach the next day
the place just felt so untouched what
actually really surprised me about that
area was how warm the ocean was it
almost seemed warmer than Northern
California during the summer what really
resonated with me about Victoria was
just how positive and passionate
everyone was about the highlight their
passion about the place is just
extremely contagious and made my
experience completely unforgettable
[Music]